[Music]
Father's Day is this Sunday and
according to the National Retail
Federation this year Americans will
spend over fourteen billion dollars on
Father's Day now unfortunately that kind
of money brings out crooks and thieves
who are ready to take advantage and scam
you out of your hard-earned dough well
my friend Andy Richter's been looking at
some common Father's Day scams he'll
tell you what to watch out for in a
segment called Andy Father's Day scam
thanks Karen the first scam is called up
the Visa yin-yang
your wife announces she's taking you to
a super fancy Father's Day brunch kids
are on their best behavior you drink
mimosas you load up at the oyster buffet
and at the end of the meal she pulls out
a credit card and that's when it hits
you all the money comes out of the same
joint checking account and you're the
only one with a paying job
you just got treated to a fancy brunch
that you paid for three hundred and
fourteen bucks including chip there's
only one word for that that's not really
a classic scam a kleenex one is called
the Arizona switchback your brother
Steve calls and says why don't we go to
Phoenix and surprise dad on Father's Day
easy for Steve he lives in Scottsdale
it's 20 minutes away but then you start
to feel bad because you don't know how
much time the old man's got left so you
say okay Steve and buy that plane ticket
a week before Father's Day Steve says
change of plans I'm driving dad to LA he
wants to see the grandkids well now I
got a host the old bastard and my
brother plus I got to eat that
non-refundable plane ticket hey Steve I
don't know what they call that in
Phoenix but out here Stern
[Applause]
now
No the idea here is we want to know
about Father's Day related credit card
fraud or identity theft you have
anything like that
this last con is called the barbecue do
you tell your sister Karen that you want
to take dad to his favorite barbecue
place for Father's Day and she's like
his blood pressures through the roof
the last thing Papa needs is more pork
so instead you go online and buy your
dead a cool model sailboat for 300 bucks
big day comes and what does your sister
get him reservations at a BBQ joint
you're like yeah Taryn
she's like young ELab watts meaning
while that model boat you ordered shows
up two days after Father's Day and when
it comes the mast is broken and look
what happens look what happens when you
called their customer service hotline
[Music]
can you believe it
it's always busy school and Father's Day
scam thank you that wasn't really what
we were looking for but anyway thanks
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
works fine great show tonight
star of the new movie love and
friendship Kate Beckinsale
[Applause]
let me walk with Wall Street in the new
CBS series wreck Brian Sokka is here
yes
musical guest Marlon Williams and the
yarra benders are here
you